is there anything you wish you'd had
someone tell you before you made
the feature was there something here and
there where if someone could just have
warned you
everything i wished i would have known i
i learned i learned from
channels like yours and other youtube
channels um where i learned how to i
mean i'm
youtube was my film school no joke um in
fact there are so i mean there's so many
channels
in thank you in my credits you guys are
in the thank you oh my credit
really you guys taught me so much right
thank you so
so everything i wished i had learned i i
made sure to learn
right um any of the pitfalls or the
warnings i got all that
in in my studies okay what can i look
out for what can i so i learned from
everyone's mistakes and
i think that's why it was such an
enjoyable easy smooth experience for us
if i really think hard about something i
wish i could have learned
i think the one thing i will say is i
wish i there was more focus on b-roll
for sure it's such a weird detail but i
wish i had learned
to shoot b-roll and plan for b-roll and
inserts
and stuff well before him because when
we got to our post
editing i had nothing i had no b-roll i
had to reshoot a bunch of stuff and it
just none of it makes sense
right inserts come on right um so that
that's one interesting detail i wish i
had really learned about beforehand was
planning for b-roll
um because we didn't and we didn't know
when we didn't have any and we had to
reshoot a ton of stuff and it was tough
um but as far as like the experience of
filmmaking no i
i heard the lessons and i took them from
all the channels i watched and whatnot
so yeah there was nothing i looked back
it's like oh man i wish i didn't do this
no i i just followed the guidelines that
people talked talk
yeah what about set photography did you
have a lot i wish we had i wish we did
um you had a few though yeah on your
facebook yes
uh we had the producers taking candid
shots
um i didn't instruct them to thank god
they did
but having a set photography is super
necessary
because uh they're one they're capturing
the moment capturing the excitement the
memories but it's so great for publicity
so great behind the scenes is so much
fun to study and look and research and
and learn about um so our producers did
take some
but uh it's not some i wish we would
have had an on set photographer
all the time but couldn't get one yeah
yeah um and i
i wasn't worried about spoilers either
because we're
we're not known so spoil the crap out of
it right
get people to know what this is oh
there's a new film what's this mean
what's that i mean great talk about it
i mean we're not like we're not like a
major major blockbuster who needs to
keep everything tight-lipped no
i want to find out yeah take pictures
leak whatever you can
i want people to find out about this
thing you know i remember when la la
land i think was like leaked
right oh right right now there was like
some pictures far away
and now you're finding now you're
finding directors like well if we're
gonna have paparazzi leak it i might as
well leak it myself
sure so at least let's get the pictures
to look good right let's get the videos
to look good
and uh yeah it's like it's like part of
the game now i think you know leaking
your stuff
to hype it up but yeah i had people
leaked my stuff i would have felt
honored
you know because no one knows about it
yet so
so when do you think it'll be out i know
you said it's up on amazon prime is it
for
use for purchase well it's currently not
on amazon prime
at this moment anymore because the film
um
the the film festival wants the world
once the world release so we
it was literally on for eight hours we
got the email saying we were in
we took it right down eight hours so it
wasn't like well
we didn't really break any rules because
like no one saw it really it was like
eight hours live
um so it will be live on amazon prime
july 1st
july 1st which is like two days after
the festival
um and then yeah it'll be live there
anyone can watch it you know
but for now we need to give the priority
to the festival understandable
you know everyone has their their
regulations and their
statuses that they need to hit so yeah
so you're going to try to find
distribution netflix whatever and if for
whatever reason that doesn't happen are
you going to do an aggregator where
you're going to then put it on video i
i thought about going through distribur
um i uh uh
they're obviously the go-to i know
distributor works directly with netflix
i mean netflix goes to distribute to
aggregate everything first like
even if you don't go through the
stripper to get to them netflix goes to
distribute right
so they're a great company for
self-distribution amazing
um i unfortunately did not have the
funds i had four thousand dollars i
don't have the funds for them
unfortunately um but they're
they're amazing so knowing
knowing the small connections i have
that's kind of the route we're going
um so like again amazon prime anyone can
get on we're we will be on a january
july 1st
um and and then from there it's about
promoting it
uh getting a budget for promotions um
and then the connections we have um i
still do a lot more research on any
other aggregation
any other services like that because i
totally think they're just
super helpful and amazing for indie
filmmakers they have doors that
sometimes we can't get into and they're
already in
and they know how to vet your film they
know how to make sure everything's tight
and up to standard right i have to learn
that without them
because i don't have the money for it so
i would love to
i would love to go through them but or
other other distribution and aggregation
stuff but
at this point we're just doing it
ourselves